Voilà alors j'ai beaucoup réfléchi et j'ai décidé d'arrêter de faire des vidéos sur youtube
Je rigole évidemment je continue les vidéos toute ma vie vers l'infini
Pour la première fois je vous fais une vidéo là c'est pas un sketch ou quoi c'est une vidéos informatives
je vais simplement vous donner quelques informations
Mes chansons ça fait très longtemps que beaucoup d'entre vous me demander quand est-ce qu'on pourra écouter mes chansons
sur des plates formes d'écoutes tels que deezer spotify est tout et moi je vous répondais
pas parce que je suis un gros bâtard
finalement j'ai pris tout ça en main et désormais vous écouter librement toutes mes chansons sur deezer spotify apple musique et itunes
à vous de choisir
j'ai regroupé tous ces morceaux se forme une playlist mais j'ai pas trop comment l'appeler parce que c'est vrai que c'est ni un album ni
un ep et le terme compilation ça faisait un peu années 90 il norman
compilation qui demeure 2017 avec ton booty tout l'été sur des rythmes chaudement haute avec chérie fm et produit par michel blanc
salut c'est michel blanc sur chérie fm j'ai produit cet album et c'est de la bande de balle fils de pute du coup j'ai appelé
ça mais gros son même s'ils sont pas spécialement gros bref culture dans le bus dans la cour de récré dans ton putain taf
peut écouter zelda luigi clash mario franson
internet de l'époque assassins des templiers et assassins des templiers version acoustique soyez pas étonné s'il ya un ou deux morceaux manquants
c'est en cours donc à les écouter ça sur vos plateformes préférées
mauvais votre nas chaîne secondaire autre grande nouvelle que j'ai désormais une chaîne youtube secondaire c'est-à-dire une deuxième chaîne youtube j'ai tout simplement appelée
norman le chêne secondaire bon arrêtez les vrais savent que c'est une vieille chaîne secondaire que je ressors des abysses
Dessus je mets plein de vidéos je me prends un peu moins la tête des vidéos un peu improvisé
freestyle l'occurrence en ce moment beaucoup de vidéos de gaming notamment avec hugo à mais pas que
s'appelle gaming entre potes qu'éminent entrepôts et ça va être qu'avant clair
et on dit des conneries un peu plus cru que d'habitude vu que c'est une chaîne secondaire on s'en fout no limit no filter
Et puis des fois il y aura des poteaux en invité pour jouer avec nous par exemple les prochains c'est les frérots de la vega
non non frérot ses berlines je suis déçu il ya un bus le 8 mars
pour l'instant j'ai pas appeler ça norman gaming
parce que déjà ses prix en a déjà fait son sprint sur toi en tout le monde et en plus de sueur a pas que
du gaming
Et peut-être que sur cette chaîne bientôt il y aura aussi des petits débats entre potes des ambiances radios libres avec les abonnés bref cette
chaîne c'est un peu un labo quoi ouais j'ai une chaîne labo si vous aimez l'idée
abonnez vous les abonnés dans ma vidéo vous le savez peut-être mais bientôt grâce à vous on va passer la barre des 10 millions
d'abonnés youtube
Pour fêter ça je vais me bourrer la gueule mais aussi je prépare une grosse vidéo youtube
enfin une vidéo assez grosse enfin plus grosse que les autres
et vu que mine de rien cette aventure youtube passé grâce à vous j'ai envie que vous fassiez partie de cette vidéo
j'ai besoin de vous avez dû je vais rien vous spoiler mais en gros c'est une petite histoire que j'ai inventé et à un moment
donné dans cette histoire je vois mes abonnés en train de regarder mes vidéos pour participer envoyez moi une vidéo
devenue en train de norman non ça c'est le casting de morandini ça
ah merde ok mais plus sérieusement pour participer envoyez moi une vidéo de vous d'environ une minute
vous faites style de regarder des vidéos tu vois en rigolant ou en souriant donc si mes vidéos font pas rire du tout
bas fait semblant 1 s'il vous plaît il faut que ce soit filmé avec la caméra intérieure de votre téléphone tablette ou ordinateur
eux sans regarder l'objectif en regardant l'écran ça doit être bien cadré bien éclairé c'est important en souriant ou en rigolant légèrement sans en faire
des caisses vous pouvez aussi le faire sur un ordi ça doit durer une minute comme ça un os un peu flou mais je vous
ça rendra bien inutile de faire des trucs exubérant ou de parler hein et
norman le sort que tu peux passer un big up au lycée jean moulin
merci mon frère tout tout seul parce que sera pas cohérent avec le reste
alors je pourrai pas le mettre dans le montage et envoyez votre vidéo à go to 10 millions @ gmail point com
par mail par ouï transfert comme vous voulez attention évidemment tout le monde ne pourra pas être dans le montage final même si j'en ai
très envie
je peux pas mettre 10 millions de vidéos dans montage final ça ferait une vidéo de huit heures donc je vais devoir un moment
sélectionner un petit peu au hasard en tirant au sort évidemment en présence d'huissiers donc je suis ici avec m blanchard
et m maître gims
voilà avant de donner les résultats je tiens à dire que les votes ont été très serrés non mais je ne sens n'a pas commencé
le concours a pas commencé ta t'as pas compris cette vidéo d'information est désormais terminé tout de suite la météo présentée par
bonsoir alors il fera 18 degrés à lille 14 degrés à toulouse
Bref j'espère que vous avez kiffé ses petites infos plutôt positive
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à ma chaîne youtube secondaire que vous connaissez maintenant et aussi à ma chaîne youtube principal pour atteindre les 10
millions d'abonnés c'est maintenant ou jamais et dès qu'on passe la barre des 10 millions je sors une vidéo exceptionnelle avec vous dedans
j'ai juste hyper hate you tube 10 millions ciao